إنه شيء واحد إذا تعرضت شخصيات خيالية
مثل كرامر
أو صوفيا
للضرب من قبل لعبة البيسبول ولكن
لا يوجد شيء خيالي حول
أسطورة البث اليانكي جون ستيرن
يانكيز عندما كان لا يزال يدير
خط توقيعه بعد لحظات فقط من ضرب
جاستن تورنر لاعب فريق ريد سوكس الثالث
كرة كريهة ضربت ستيرلنج.
تأرجح Noggin Three Two على خطأ مفاجئ
هنا واو
واو،
أشاد مشجعو Yankee بالأخو البالغ من العمر 84 عامًا
وهو أكثر متانة من لاعبينا، لذا
أخذت واحدة للفريق، أنا بخير، مجرد
ضربة خاطفة أرسلها أحد المعجبين جون
ستيرلنج، إنها مثل Timex  ذروتها
تتطلب لعقًا وتستمر في الدق لكنك
تعلم ما الذي لم يستمر في وضع علامة على
طائرة بدون طيار التي تحدى مستخدم اليوتيوب المعروف باسم السيد
بيست توم برادي ليطرد
من السماء أول محاولة
[موسيقى]
برادي خدع الطائرة بدون طيار، لقد
خدعها ستيرلنج  تم نقل الكرة التي يبثها
الشريك لاحقًا إلى Red Sox
Clubhouse،
وعادت
مزينة بضمادة تطابق
حرب الجنيه الاسترليني ونقش من
الخليط وكتب جاستن تورنر إلى
جون بغض النظر عن المكان الذي تجلس فيه في
مباراة الكرة  أنت لست آمنًا أبدًا، كم هو لطيف
أنني معجب جدًا لأنه لم يستخدم أي كلمات بذيئة
[تصفيق]
ثلاث بومة وما زال لم يخرج من
العبقرية سي إن إن